chapter two who is I
you know this obviously comes after
getting some sort of traction
um under what is I yes
um after gaining okay all right so I has
to be me all right I'm given a name
that's slapped onto me like a label on a
milk jug okay so then what is what is
the contents that the label is on
yeah I think we start there yeah nice
right so and how do you determine who
you how do you determine who that is
right I I think you did a good job of
saying it's like a label slapped onto an
item
and if we can look at our name as a
label slapped onto a piece of life then
the question is what is the life or what
is the I before the label and then we
begin to say okay well could it be that
you know that what's underneath of the
labels is potentially the same and are
is that I then just playing as the
characters for the label or or the label
is just you know the label for the
character yes yeah
um
yeah I mean and again
we we introduced this at chapter two
because I feel like it's it's the
subtleness to it because chapter two
really could be the end but I feel like
we kind of dance into you know okay okay
you're playing a character what is the
character we can get into that but
um just just knowing that you're playing
a character should you know act I would
say like okay well then what is this
character what is the character doing
what are the properties of this
character you know uh what what can I do
best to make this character perform at
its peak what does that even look like
so again now we investigate life seems
different now I'm asking different
questions on a daily basis yes as to
what I should be doing or not doing and
why am I thinking or not thinking this
way yes yes
right and this
around this time would be a good time to
begin opening up to the idea of the play
so the characters in the play um so
obviously because there's a lot going on
around here yeah I'm here so yes yes so
then
um when we begin sort of opening
ourselves up to the idea of the play and
uh I
potentially being what's behind all the
characters in the play
um we can begin sort of
uh having a deeper level of
Investigation especially in the form of
a play with characters I think that's
such a crucial element to our book yeah
a play with characters yeah yes yeah I
mean that's that's pretty much all I
have to say because again I don't want
to have the tendency of like going all
the way forward so we got to keep them
right where we exactly yes I think that
is really the core for chapter two who
was I
um
right now you're a character
yeah and we and you know that like look
at the definition of a character like
that is what you are at this moment
yeah and and actually when you do uh
when you do buy the book and you look
through it and you're reading it you'll
actually see us distilling down the
definitions
um of these words that are typically uh
who looks up the definition of what i is
right or character because like you kind
of know like oh you know characters as a
person or a thing in some sort of play
or movie or or book right yeah exactly
exactly exactly right right
yeah yeah
so who is i i as a character yeah and
that's what we know right now that's
what we can we can prove that we can
prove that without a shadow of a doubt
and that is what this book is about
proving it to yourself where it is it is
really known in in in a truth to your
core again versus someone just telling
you nice and that is where the word
conviction comes in um
felt direct experience yes yes yes no
one can tell you otherwise amen